JD had a weed gummy this weekend and
then I said well how much was in it you
know there's a this the amount of the
grams milligram said he was worried when
we went to LA how many Milligan he goes
I don't even know where I loose a little
bit and probably a little too much and I
don't like to be out of control and this
is like one of those rare times where I
stupidly let myself out of control a
little bit
he had a margarita which is a margarita
infused with weed honey okay weed
gummies and three bottles of wine in
addition to the margarita what I didn't
have like three bottles although myself
well just split it with one other person
sure one bottle of wine is about seven
drinks JD I don't through the math I
just do the drinking no surprise here JD
got very buzzed mm-hmm then agreed to be
interviewed while he was inebriated we
started by asking JD when was the last
time he that he cried when was the last
time you cried oh I cry all the time
crying right now like right now I'm
tearing Oh si why are you tearing I
don't know what is making I don't know
like maybe when I get self introspective
or something but I mean I've drinking a
margarita so maybe that's part of I
don't know are you mixing up crying with
your eyes watering well that's I don't
know that's there's something going on
with Reid I just I don't know or I ever
realize yet I cried when she partly with
clothes and I was hungry at this point
the edibles and the wine were really
kicking in and so of course they started
asking him about his co-workers uh who's
your favorite and least favorite staff
member my favorites ever with John Hines
my best friend Jason Kaplan least
favorite cuz he's the biggest markets
biggest staff narc describe Chris
Wilding in a few words
Wilding yeah look he likes the attention
Christ okay describe Gary Dell'Abate a
few words yo Gary Tawaf a talkative um
[ __ ] dogs are going I described will in
a few words
well in a few words I cannot I wonder
who would cantankerous lovable but also
he just came here he can give you an
attitude if I'm calling will level one
definitely [ __ ] up here he is sniffing
his wine glass and stuffing his face oh
we saw him finish this recently in Jesus
God it's almost like a less sweet apple
juice while ago any very good instance
and some cheese good
JD was so drunk and stoned that he
wanted to do some karaoke you want to
hear that I can pass it on this [ __ ]
couch right
[Music]
so pain
[Music]
there's JD doing thriller do you
remember any of this
like the drips and drabs JD's wild that
was crowded mouth you like feeling like
it was just one night I felt comfortable
in my surroundings and you know I'd had
fun thank goodness you don't feel
comfortable very often very true